I'm just curious speaking of music what was like
your first concert because we talked a lot with
music with you okay yeah so my first concert and I
was trying to think of this I think it was Natalie
Merchant whoa and I think my friends and I choose
to be the same age yeah I was gonna say yeah she's
playing in Newport Rhode Island and I grew up in
Middletown Rhode Island my friends and I rode our
bikes and snuck into the concert because it was
outdoors and uh saw our first concert I think
I was pretty young yeah wow what was your first
concert it was uh Prince Purple Rain tour 1984.
yeah that's a good one yeah and and I was only
23 now so I was a lot of In Utero recollection
of being in it you know your first concert
my first concert that's a good start yeah
it's incredible I still remember oh
my God I still remember the white
dove he he traded the fender for the
White Dove guitar for Purple Rain it
was just uh still in my still in
my mind grapes right now what a
[Laughter]
you get all the time [Music] foreign
[Applause]
[Music]